germany's far-right has failed in its
attempt to send
shockwaves across the political
landscape in a regional election
exit polls show angela merkel's
conservatives have comfortably seen off
a challenge from the alternative for
germany
in the eastern state of saxony anhalt
the afd did not manage to win
a surprise victory over the chancellor's
party but the far right
still makes up the second biggest block
in the regional parliament
so voting has now ended so let's take a
look at the projected results based on
exit polls taken throughout the day as
you can see there angela merkel's
conservatives the cdu are on 35.9
the far right afd on 22.7
the socialist left party 10.9 the center
left
spd on 8.3 the environmentalists
greens on 6.5 and the business friendly
ftp
on 6.4
right well to talk about the
significance of these results i'm joined
by
dw political correspondent hans brandt
here in the studio hi hans and welcome
to the program
and dw's chief political editor mikhail
koffner who joins us from
magdeburg right so i'm going to start
with michaela um
michaela angela merkel cdu has emerged
from the election
well ahead of the afd yet saxony anhalt
is a
relatively small german state so why
does this regional election
matter so much
well like so often in life it's the
timing because this is
the last test ahead of those uh
elections
in at the end of september that will
mark the end of the mackel era
and we'll decide what comes next but
it's also because it's one of those
eastern states where the afd
did particularly well in the past and is
still actually doing well
it came out of nowhere five years ago
almost got 25
now just around about 22 percent and
angela marco's party really
bouncing back here and exceeding all
expectations one can say because the
next question we have to ask what's up
with those opinion polls
and even the most optimistic one put
anger mackel's cdu party
not above 30 percent now it might be
36 if these exit polls translate into
results
and nobody had seen the afd do below 23
and that is exactly
what happened here according to those
exo polls
so a big question marks over how much
the polling is worth
and a resounding victory for the
conservative cdu
party which it badly needs going into
what has
so far been a rather shaky election
campaign
right so resounding victory it appears
for the cdu now many thought
michaela that the the afd party could
win
but what did the cdu offer that the afd
couldn't
well it did offer a much more
conservative tone
then many conservatives actually fear
is mainstream angela mackel of course
often having criticized for having
shifted the party more
towards the center reiner haslow the
state premier
quite clearly gained trust and
popularity over those past
five years and that is something that
we've also seen in previous
regional elections that often appear to
be the exception from
the general rule of what the average
polling shows in germany
its personality politics quite clearly
and that's also a signal to all parties
going
into the run-up to those general
elections
in september that it's the personality
that matters
and that can prove to be then an
exception
to the rule of what the national polling
is showing and that certainly worked for
the conservative cdu and reiner hazel of
the state premier here
all right we'll leave it there for the
moment mikhail koffner we're going to
turn to you hans here in the studio what
does
this result say or actually what does
this victory mean on a national level
for the cdu is it likely that the party
will repeat this success
in september oh it's a very early days
talking about the election at the end of
september
of course the cdu will take a boost from
this because they did
very well very very well here and so
they will feel that this will give them
a boost ahead of the
elections in september uh but we have to
see that this is a very small
state there are two million people
living there out of more than 80 million
people in germany
so this result cannot be copied onto the
german national
scene and on a on a national level
the greens will be a lot more uh
challenging for the
conservatives than they have been in
this state and all the other
morally second-ranking parties too will
have a lot stronger
showing on the national level that does
not go for the afd the afd in fact is
nationally is weaker than it is here in
this state which is one of its
core states so the elections
will give some sort of boost for the
conservatives
uh but they're not at all a prediction
of results uh
for the end of september for the
national elections well what's your main
takeaway from all of this then if you're
saying that it's not
you know very reflective perhaps of the
rest of the country but what is it that
you're
maybe surprised about at first glance or
maybe not surprised
i think what you can say here is that
the greens did not do as well as they
had hoped and they are hoping to do very
well to get very close at least to the
conservatives on a national level
and you have to look at all the somewhat
smaller parties the three democrats the
business friendly party the social
democrats who are now also
more or less a second ranking party the
greens and also the
far left party all of them are hoping to
do much better
in the national polls and as a result to
have some chance of becoming part of a
government because there will have to be
a coalition government
at national level and the question is
who the conservatives the strongest
party most likely
are going to need or going to want to
have a coalition with
all right we're going to leave it there
for the moment dw political
correspondent hans
brandt and dw's chief political editor
mikhail kufna in saxony and health
thanks to both of you
right we'll cross over to the regional
headquarters of the afd in a moment but
first a
look now at why the afd was thought to
pose such a threat to the christian
democrats in eastern germany
clairefoot is an idyllic little town one
of germany's largest medieval castles
sits right in its center life is
tranquil here
there is hardly any crime
may 2021 was campaigning season
hans thomas hilschnel represents the afd
in the local council
as well as in saxony angel state
parliament
one in three people in fairfoot has
voted for the afd in the past
ted schneider won over voters with
messages that play well here
we will introduce free daycare and free
school lunches we will also start a
deportation offensive and immediately
deport all immigrants who don't have a
residency permit
blanket prejudices of this sort about
immigrants and refugees
find considerable support here take
foreigners for example because
foreigners have more special rights here
than we germans do and that's not okay
yet there are hardly any foreigners to
be found this can be traced back to the
history of east germany
the german democratic republic or gdr
was a separate country from the rest of
germany until
1990 and it was a socialist dictatorship
authoritarian and militaristic social
diversity was not desired immigration
was only rarely allowed
gdr citizens overthrew the government
germany was reunified
but the economy and social
infrastructure of the former east
germany collapsed
many people felt that they were let down
and had lost out
a sentiment that continues to shape the
social climate
over the last 25 years we have observed
that many young people
who were very mobile and had ideas for
shaping their own lives
decided to leave eastern germany for
social economic and cultural reasons
and those who stayed here even the
younger generation
tended to be the ones who were most
cautious the most fearful
perhaps even the ones most likely to
articulate these prejudices
and these are exactly the people the afd
reaches out to
you
even
the afd courts them claiming to be the
party that will solve all their problems
but they also act divisively
when we rule the country one day then i
promise you these shady mobs will have
another thing coming
and then a new day will dawn for you
afd voters don't mind radical speeches
and they don't mind the fact that till
schneider has ties to right-wing
extremists
on the contrary what they want here is a
party who rejects what democratic
germany stands for
a culturally diverse society
right well dw correspondent benjamin
alvarez gruba
is at the alternative for germany party
headquarters in saxony
and halt hi benjamin it looks like the
afd will end up with
a smaller share of the vote than the
last election in saxony unhealth
how's the party reacting where you are
that's right it was a surprise but
politicians here after politicians who
went to the stage
have said that they managed to retain
the voters of the last elections they
are still saying
it's a success we just had the party top
candidate
saying that this was a sign and a boost
ahead of the general elections in
september but of course
if we consider that there were some
polls showing the farad afd party even
in
in the lead against the conservative
party of chancellor
angela merkel of course these numbers
aren't as high as the ones that they
expected
i mean what does this result mean for
the afd heading into september's
election
well it's a rather symbolic election we
just heard it from our colleague
michaela kifna
who said 1.2 million voters are were
invited to cast the ballots
today so it's rather symbolic it's a
boost for the current state premier
who will now will go into coalition
talks it could be either
the green party the social democrats the
spd or the business friendly
fdp party it's important to note that
even if the afd had
reached the majority it would not have
been able to get into the coalition with
other parties as
all the other parties have said that
they would not have a coalition for them
so for them it's an important boost
several afd politicians have talked
went to the stage here and have said
that it is a success that they are
showing that people still want to follow
them especially the programs
that they had here in the state in the
eastern state of saxony andhra that has
been rather
nationalistic and even more radical than
in other parts of the country so
even though the numbers could not be
reached the numbers that they tried
it to show and the numbers that several
polls have shown
they are trying to sell it as a success
right so they're trying to sell it as a
success you said it there the
pre-election poll suggested the result
would be much closer
why do you think that the afd failed to
build on its vote share though
it might be that the cdu now also
campaigned in the last days since the
sports came out showing
that a far-right party would reach a
majority in the state
they tried also to appeal to voters we
just had tina kopala
one of the top parties candidates saying
that people here
voted more conservative but it's
important to remember that the efd
is a far-right party it is under
surveillance in several parts
of the country and the youth
organization of this party is also under
surveillance by
domestic intelligence agencies so that's
something you would heard
from politicians of the party trying to
show themselves
as a conservatives but they are far more
on the right spectrum
of the of the political spectrum all
right we leave it there dw correspondent
benjamin alvarez gruber thanks so much
right well joining me now is helga lint
member of the german bundestag
for the social democrats he's been
managing
uh he's been campaigning against
right-wing extremism and racism on the
national level
for years hi helga now the afd seems to
have been
strongly defeated by the cdu still
almost
one in four people in saxony and held
votes far right
how much does that worry you
it worries me a lot i'm happy that uh
it's good for the democracy that has
love and it was
mainly hazelov's personal ssx
that he was successful for the cdu
and that he stopped the um
development of the afd but there's still
more than 20 of the population of the
voters
pro afd and you must know that the afd
and
saxony arnold is a very right-wing
extremist afd their leader mr keshner
was a member of the flugel this
folkish nationalist wing of the
afd so this is the hardest part the most
extremist part of the aft to
speak clearly right so they're what
about their positions so you're talking
about the positions they're taken by the
afd in saxony anhalt
but overall is the afd becoming more
mainstream in germany
well it's a paradox i think we
have to see but we should not accept it
that's getting a kind of normality to
have
on the federal level for the
federal elections maybe 10 11 12
for the afd it's less in the western
states
it's clearly more in the eastern states
on the other hand
if you look at the program if you look
at the personalities
if you look at the statements in the
parliament
they get more and more aggressive so
they
don't move towards the center they move
towards
the right wing so it's a paradox
development but i think we see some
tendencies
that they try to combine certain issues
on the one hand as we see it in section
arnaud
the question of immigration
fight against globalization diversity
on the other hand they strengthen their
competent their their issues on the
social
justice level to get workers for the
support so double strategy in these
eastern countries right well moving to
your party the spd
they've lost even more votes this time
in saxony and halt
why do you think that is well
we had kind of showdown so people
even supporters of the social democratic
party and of the green party
they decided to give their votes to
hasselhoff
to stop the success of the afd
so it was a tactical decision of them
and on the other hand we have to be
honest that
if you look at the polls many people
in saxony and out in countries with a
comparable structural situation have
lost confidence in the idea of
social justice promoted by the social
democratic party so it's a
long long term loss of confidence
right well looking at what we at the
exit poll so far what does this
regional election teach you considering
there are national elections in germany
in september
well of course the
cdu the christian democrats will say
it's a tendency for the federal election
i think
it's more complicated because it was a
special
situation in a small country and
it was a decision not for
mr lushad but mainly for mr haselof
so everything is open we can see
that the ceo can win election but
they can also lose we see that the trend
towards a victory of the green party may
might be stopped by i think the
forthcoming month will decide a lot it
will be
a battle so to speak between
the candidates between berg
lashed and schultz and this will be the
decision
all right we'll leave it there german
lawmaker helga lint thank you for your
analysis there
thank you bye
right well voting has now ended so let's
actually take a look at the projected
results
angela merkel's conservatives the cdu
are on 36
the far right afd on 22.7
the socialist left party on 10.8 the
center left
spd on 8.3 the environmentalist
greens on 6.6 and the business friendly
ftp
on 6.5
you